I live a double life I'm not just a
chemist I will always hold true to my
heart
I got into graffiti 25 years ago with
hip-hop I was fascinated by this
underground movement at the time I was a
teenager trying to find an energy skill
unity from the lyrics of an MC to wild
flow and bright colors of graffiti
I missed the old time with my crew p19
crew it's like a family we look out for
each other there's a couple of ice that
default realism in Manchester blacks is
shut it down to Irvine ah I moved to
Manchester in 1997 to study chemistry
then found a job as a scientist the old
days of Manchester which was the Wild
West and the free part is today creative
artistic place to be street art half of
the Northwest if I used to paint on
abandoned spots nowadays I paint public
spaces but I still use spray paint well
my work is done freehand takes years of
practice to master the art of spray
painting so it's like in the time I
start scrubbing Kabong they say that you
don't choose a weapon a weapon chooses
you
it's the same with accent he didn't
choose to do street art street art chose
in the street artist I realize about the
impact my art can have on people my
recent tribute of David Bowie is the
perfect example like most of my students
they have daytime jobs outside of that
that's not the real person the real
person is an artist or maybe a musician
this was a surprise to show me what he
was capable of and to me I just thought
it was absolutely unbelievable
I find it increasingly difficult to
paint with my full-time job and my
family but they will never give up my
passion and always hold true to my art
spray painting is my life
[Music]